pump the brakes there gang get over to
that are you garbage.com and pick up
some ayg gear we're talking T Zippo
style lighters you got the kippies
heaters and cooling you got the garbage
shirts you got the Bernie shirts do
yourself a favor pick something up for
the one you love also it's the one stop
shop for all ayg Live show tickets maybe
there's still some tickets left to the
second show but it's going to sell out
in Red Bank New Jersey get those tickets
now Friday August 11th don't snooze
Cause You're Gonna Lose yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of
[Music]
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the group to be classy
yeah after just a big old piece of trash
I'm your host Dave Foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're out back here
at hoodies in the new edition baby she
is upstairs in a room watching a little
Dog the Bounty Hunter and having some
screwdrivers just getting their Summer
started the right way my co-host is
coming at you from across the table this
is a family episode he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he's an international
businessman and when it's a summertime
baby he's a king of the boardwalk give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube and as you know those numbers
are fruit around
and obviously
www.patreon.com are you garbage boys
grab a newspaper that thing is
uh and then obviously I mean you sign up
you get bonus episodes ayg get all the
bonus videos the road stuff that we do a
whole years of content on there you sign
up right you get right you get access
right away then uh we got merch over at
Ru garbage.com we got t-shirts and Zippo
style lighters access to all the tickets
we have on the road more dates coming
soon look at you with that that was very
succinct yes I'm a succinct kind of guy
it's very good having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones Works to twos crosses the t's
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody
what's up dudes what up t-barn beautiful
summer day we got beautiful about to
fire up the grill I'm trying the
wakeboard dude I'm going to get out
there get some summertime activities
going man you ride your skateboard to
titties today I sure did he did I saw it
out there yeah it was great about the
roofing
get out of here you hippie bastard
you're punching security guards on your
way here I let some people know what
time it is not a crime dude
I beat up a couple of jocks on your way
here yeah the beef continues
until the day I die
long hair freak I'll tell you that gang
we're here for a family episode I wanted
to ask you guys this what's that
um oh that's cold water baby summer is
kicked off sure when you were young men
okay were you ever sent away in the
summer were you ever sent off to an
aunts and uncles for the weekend for the
week go with your cousins without your
parents yeah you were all the time down
the shore get out of my mom's hair sure
the sure I know but that is just what
that's what we had what my Aunt Patty
had a house in Sea Isle shout out to
Aunt Patty uh and Patty and Uncle John
uh and Patty had a house in Sea Isle big
old house riddled with asbestos I'm sure
his name was from like the 1800s it's an
old Acme
and uh yeah one parent or one Aunt
whether it was my Aunt Patty or
sometimes she was working so Aunt Carol
Mikey's mom would be down there and like
one aunt or
and watch everybody during the week I'll
watch all the kids during the week while
the parents were at home working it's
like Lord of the Flies yeah
it was you know everybody had bikes the
baits you know boogie boards the whole
nine yards yeah what about you I went
down to Myrtle Beach with my with my
aunt and uncle and my cousins I'm not
talking about scoring fireworks and then
driving back
hey man we had to pick some stuff up
play it cool at the border will you
yeah no it was we got an ounce of
crystal up your ass we stated this
horrible
Crystal Mueller I know he's Chris when
you call it Crystal that means you're in
the game
it's meth or crystal meth or methamphet
you don't say I got a [__] ounce of
crystal on me that's for a guy who's
already dipped into the bag
Crystal means you're banging
slang Crystal t
T ice I'll give you real you gotta get
off the ice cream yeah shut up shut up
is always a doggy we get a guy in the
back of the car be looking at him the
guys he likes them always light him a
cig like it was about the [__] uh
face the firing squad if you were cool
with dog he was cool with you oh yeah
he's not you were getting the bear spray
yeah
which I don't think they were allowed to
have by the way those guys played it
fast like ninjas what are you talking
about that ponytail they didn't have
like sirens or special license plates no
I mean I don't think bounty hunters do
that's how he got jammed up I'm sure we
talked about this but that's how we got
jammed up that's how he became famous
what there was a guy who murdered
somebody I think it was from the Estee
Lauder family and he ran down to Mexico
like you know was on the road 14 guys
and he was wanted and dog just went down
there and kidnapped the guy and brought
him back I had to bring them back to the
U.S like no jurisdiction no nothing yeah
Jack the dude up yeah that that's all
Bounty hunting's an odd profession I as
a Young Man uh uh would go they would
send me and my brother up to my uncle
Bernie's out at the lake shout out to
him
Uncle eaters and Uncle Bernie
that's those two didn't have kids yeah
my uncle my they'd send us out to my
uncle Bernie's like like once every
summer out to I think it was Lake
silkworth if I'm not if I'm not mistaken
I'm damn right like crawler full like
silkworth that's what it was called and
we go up there and my cousin Joe would
roll in he was about five years older my
cousin Carol would be there and uh he'd
take us fishing and all that stuff it
was real like you know out with the boys
kind of vibe sure yeah yeah yeah and
then famously when my grandmother was
sick my mom sent me to uh like a distant
cousins for like about a month while my
grandmother was sick my brother got to
go to my aunt Mary Catherine and Uncle
Mary or my Aunt Mary Catherine and my
uncle Reds and really live it up over on
WB
I got sent out to the sticks with a
bunch of kids I didn't know yeah no
that's slept on a fold out couch I don't
know I was like three years old yeah I
don't know if that's still fully the
story I think Patty's throws some
[__] smoke and mirrors every time
that's brought up that ain't the real
story it was either her and your dad
were about to get a divorce or she was
out hooking or something
without me in a post office box
it's a hundred dollar bill staple
dealers that one summer they sent me to
the Firehouse for about three months
concerned am I keep
fighting the dalmatian for a couple of
scraps
uh yeah that's why I never and none but
that was the yeah the growing up the
thing was get went get to the shore how
you gonna get to the shore who's gonna
bring you back it was like my mom's
driving down Aunt Carol can bring you
home in three Sundays or whatever it was
just get down what'd you do for cash
down there what do you mean would you
get broken off before you left
oh I mean I wasn't I didn't like at what
age at like seven and stuff sure five
six seven like you know parents I mean
my aunt was you want to get candy or
something like that yeah I'm sure my mom
gave money to my aunt or whatever but I
mean that also at that point you weren't
getting handed 20s maybe Mike maybe I
might have had like 40 bucks in my bag
or something I I mean not that it's not
got a chain wallet on walking around
with a [__] billfold full of hundreds
I was hitting the board I was eating hot
dogs and fudgy wedgies the whole week it
was you know I mean five bucks a day
kept me too sweet
uh yeah and I'm sure my aunt and my mom
gave my aunt uh you know I don't know
about that yeah that's when my mom went
like full time back to work after the
divorce just pedaling us off on anybody
anybody with a hundo uh no camp for you
I assume
a little very summer very little my
sister worked at a camp like a day like
uh you know she was like a camp
counselor for a long time uh and I would
go to that maybe one or two summers
right right right uh like a street like
a hockey camp we did that was like a
week long or like you know Monday
through Friday or whatever type [__] uh
I did do uh
I think I had to tell you this like a
band camp
uh no it was technically a Summer music
program uh-huh and it was at uh it was
at a it was at a college out by you uh
or sinus no Breyer wood or ah [__] uh
it's like a small it might even be a
junior college God damn it real small
private Swarthmore no Briar Meyer yeah
that's exactly
Bryn Mawr no I'll uh harkem Arkham
junior college harkham junior I gotta
see if that comes up
[Laughter]
Junior College that's wow the fact that
that came back to me you went to Procol
Harum Music Camp doing Whiter Shade of
Pale all summer uh
well you play the bridge and I'll let
you know no you fat
yeah harcum College where is that hold
on I'm sorry this is man this is
bringing it back holy [__]
yeah oh it's in Bryn Mawr it's from Bryn
Mawr I couldn't think of Bryn Mawr a
harkham junior college in Bryn Mawr
whatever it was I was in a band back in
the day you know young this is seventh
grade maybe eighth grade look at him
she's getting all mad you're not the
only musician okay [__] sunny day
over here
uh look at my keyboard
play White rain or whatever you were
just singing what was it called a
lighter shade of fat Whiter Shade of
Pale it's a famous song your remix would
be a thicker cut of bacon whatever
exercise
[Laughter]
give me an extra inside of mail foreign
so we went wait a minute back this the
[__] up was it a sleep away camp no you
could have slept there but there was no
AC in the dorms which I found out I
thought you'd be in like a van or
something like that trying to get the
full experience no so I've had to talk
about this at some point in the past
three years no Toby the band camp summer
music program
three things I take the checkbook away
from me if I knew that what are you nuts
but this whole operation is being run by
a goddamn nerd yeah this [__]
[__] School of Rock over here
it was very that kind of
you were in there training to be
security
let me guess I'm a groupie I'm just
blowing all the other kids
[Laughter]
Penny Lane was your instructor did the
weekend and you won the Battle of the
Bands and your summer fling's heart I
know so all right so what happened was
we were you were a loser all right
soccer camp lacrosse game I told you I
daycare something I just said I did all
of that
well you're going this is what you
should do I started the story with I
have done that I just picture this movie
opening up with like listen we were
trying to make a demo okay
we gotta get Jeff Chris down here to fix
it professionally Rick Rubin wasn't
picking up my calls okay I had to get to
him somehow and the first stop was
harcum Junior College I just picture the
opening shot is there's like a bus in
front of like a bus a bus station and
the bus pulls away and it's just you
with like a saxophone case in your hand
are you gonna name the album harcum
Asylum that's pretty good
um
seventh grade
seventh grade maybe eight maybe as I
think it was going into uh
uh going into eighth grade maybe okay
right around that 12 13 whatever that
age is
um
and uh we somebody got a I guess it was
online maybe they saw something or a
pamphlet or something and it was like
you go there and you could go as a band
oh I just figured the A and R guy saw
you
right yeah
it's Kevin Ryan that's caddy mate
there's Keith Richards
uh uh and I saw you in Fiddler on the
Roof want you to come down to mccamp
oh my God
oh
holy [__] man talk about finding a
little piece of gold
do a little digging he's gotta do a
little digging I could have swai swear
to God I would have brought this out
years ago I thought I had
nothing on this you don't remember no so
uh we we could join as a band or as like
an individual so it's solo
I want to do my own stuff
the lead singer of the band
who's springing for this the piece uh my
dad this was like
man the eye roll he probably gave when
he wrote that check no he was into music
it wasn't like
he was in like fog hat
he was a big Stones guy give him a
little shelter
[Laughter]
bro
oh my God I remember sitting in this
dorm room sweating my [__] ball sacks
off we got bamboozled so let all right
so the idea was
you could join as a band or as like an
individual and they would pair up
individuals when they got there and it
was like a week long he just played
every day and then at the end like what
did you play your base my bad two yeah
you made it sound like it's not a real
base oh would you play your base yeah
one string yeah
I bet there was a lot of toppy going to
do
what do they have instructors that would
like teach you the basics I'm trying no
it was like you joined as like no it was
for accredited musicians it wasn't just
like it wasn't for first timers all
right this is for people who play gigs
I had a couple of gigs under my belt we
did the Talon Show and The 50-year
Anniversary did you go as a band Yes a
group of us did was flip involved in
this uh uh I don't think so or was he
still with Emerson Lake and Palmer at
the time
I think this was maybe pre-flipper
because that's when the band started to
gel when flip came on the scene nah I
came up with this bad attitude and tore
us apart solid musician yeah he's great
good kid shout out to uh zinski check
out flips mayanzinski
um
I uh no so we joined I think it was like
three or four I think it was three of us
one two three it was a guitarist the
drummer bases me and then when we got
there they they threw in another uh
guitarist who like didn't have a home
man this kid that's poison it was a wet
noodle this kid stunk a rama where I
mean could Shred the kid could shred
I'll give him that he did a rendition of
[__] AC DC that'll blow your hair
back uh but he stung I kept I've always
tried to find this kid like one time a
year I'll go why I don't know just to
see what he's up to see if he's still
[__] melting faces there's nothing he
stole any of my lyrics
hey that riff was mine man that Fruit by
the footliffer is mine uh
uh yeah so we went and it was like you
worked all week on like covers you know
what I mean like whatever with like a
really good like musician okay you know
what I mean somebody can kind of play
everything like you know a utility
player position sure probably Mitch
wanting you something like that I gotcha
he could sing he could dance he could do
it all you know he could uh so he would
like
and you would pick like maybe like four
songs we picked and then at the end of
the week on like I guess Thursday you
went to a recording studio like a proper
recording studio cuddle cut a record
that's gotta be somewhere I I I'm not
even [__] around I'm pretty sure it's
in a shoe box in the closet at my old
room at my mom's house I can picture it
in there come on hey I'll bring it up
for it should be on cassette or CD CD
okay we were the real deal cassettes
okay this ain't AirHeads you gotta get
that uh dude you know what's so funny I
I I'm surrounded by technology and have
no way to play it there's not a CD
player on that fancy computer I bought
you with the neon lights there's one in
the boom box I'll put the the down in
the basement there's a five disc changer
down in the basement yeah yeah uh
so
yeah you do you like you pick four songs
I think we did like uh
I think we did White Room by Cream of
course something by ACDC uh not help
what's the well this is what you laid
down this is what we put on wax really
uh-huh okay and I tried to fight for
some Originals they [__]
uh and then at the end of the
at the end of this
they didn't go for Diet Cokes and dinner
rolls that was the name of the album by
the way double CD Diet Coke's dinner
rolls I try to do a vending machine
Blues
oh man this sucks Stairway to Rita water
not far
that's my Lodge tongue okay let's talk
about Helix Helix baby let's talk about
Helix mattress sending the big dog big
man got one the California King uh-huh
sleeping like a baby on that thing gang
I'm telling you right now it's the best
night's sleep I ever had you go over
there you take a quiz you find out how
you like to sleep on your side on your
back whether you're fat whether you're
skinny whether you're hot whether you're
cold and then boom they match you with
the perfect mattress for you I know I'm
a Twilight man myself baby yeah king
size baby just take the heel of sleep
like the big hill asleep quiz like the
big man you got a king too I got a king
I thought I had one up one you got the
cat I was not a California no yes I'm
not an [__] uh whether you need
something that suits you uh for your
go-to sleeping position extra cushion
for your spine or cooling features to
help keep you from overheating Helix has
you covered baby and right now here's
the turkey Helix is offering 20 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners those pillows are all
right too let me tell
yeah go to helixsleep.com garbage that's
Helix sleep.com slash garbage this is
their best offer yet and won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts now do it
gang do it this episode is brought to
you by better help yes stop giving
yourself away stop giving your energy
away to other people start remembering
to take care of yourself with better
help better helps online therapy lets
you find balance and take time to focus
on what you need and better help us
completely online uh you can do therapy
wear when and where works for you
whether that's under the coverage in bed
whether that's at the local pub whatever
you want you can do it there uh I've
always said I'm a big proponent of talk
therapy I think it's a fantastic tool
through different parts of your life if
you're you know loss of a loved one the
breakup job whatever it's a tool you can
lean on and everybody's doing it it's
normalized baby if your first therapist
isn't a perfect fit you can easily
switch at any time at no extra charge
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com garbage today and you get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-h-e-l-p.com slash garbage one more
time baby get a pen get a pencil write
it down betterhelp.com garbage today do
it that's all right man uh yeah so
within on Friday I guess that was
Thursday when in the record we moved
quick back in the day you know what I
mean come on write a couple of riffs get
in there put them on wax I remember
being so nervous in the [__] I mean this
is the this is the height of [__]
radio at this point you got to get it
done tape to get it I know so and then
Friday we played uh uh
play the gig the Roxy
that was the cafeteria of Arkham Junior
College if we're being honest that'd be
awesome if they gave me the real
experience and heading in some bar
people throwing cans at us and [__] your
head's big you can't you can't shred and
your head's big uh yeah that was that
and I think it was like I think it was
like 400 bucks
to go bam but I remember pushing the we
get an album or whatever you know sure
and I think it was 900 bucks if you
stayed there we didn't say because they
just put you in the dorm and like the
the rehearsal room was just a dorm room
was it close enough what close to you we
had to get driven every day I think my
dad drove us every day yeah wow would
pick us up and drive us wow yeah man
tonight is Summer music program if any
of you aspiring singers songwriters or
musicians out there I highly recommend
it yeah uh-huh I learned a lot no it was
It was a
yeah you try to you know at [__] 11
years old you want to be a [__] rock
star you know what I mean sure you still
do making fun of you though I I did a
theater camp
you moved to North Carolina to get on
Dawson's Creek and you're breaking my
Stones when I was 11. there's [__]
balls on this guy I was 24 at the time I
went down and smoked crack
oh we have family that watches this show
Prank Caller
I forgot it's opposite day and it's
called Rock
clone Crystal when you're in the biz
um yeah I did it I did a uh a camp at uh
Forge theater in Phoenixville PA stayed
with my cousins for a week we did a
production of big rock at Candy's
Mountain you were the big rock no he was
the Candy Mountain
no I can't remember what I played it was
like a Woodstock thing my cousin was the
star of it she killed it oh yeah I just
had a small part yeah small part it was
my first step you know I just got into
the scene uh it's gotten in the biz yeah
sure it's all right though but yeah
those I mean like as a kid they were
good phonics it's different you're
getting out of your [__] comfort zone
you know what I mean because if it was
up to me I'd be sitting on the couch
watching reruns Amore eating [__]
Elio's Pizza all summer what a way to
spend the summer ah you ain't lying God
damn yeah AC cranking parents [__]
nowhere in sight couple of Elios man I
remember not having cable
but Fox did a great job it would be like
a double shot of what's Happening a
double shot of Hogan's Heroes it was
[__] a good time throwing a prices
right in there a live Price is Right I
watch it every day at 11. wait that was
great that's clean the living I'll tell
you this what
you get your hands on that CD
I'll shop it around to a couple of guys
yeah right no you get your hands on that
I'll break out the uh the short film
that's back there what short film the
short film that I did in North Carolina
it's right back there ah no but see this
is
you want to show people
yes you do you run out of movie theater
you'd have a red carpet all we need is a
couple eyeballs
this is how he operates yeah [__]
doing a red carpet and [__] so why why
why did you first see Henry act you got
your parents there and [__] that's the
difference I would just like to hear it
that's all yeah I also don't want to see
your short film that you're gonna I'm
sure try to [__] sell me the options
too at some point man if you're gonna do
this embarrassing [__] I guess I can
bring my old movie I mean I
you are such a [__] fat idiot
you are such a ham I tell you what if
you play that I'll bring in my episode
of manifest yeah
number one show on Netflix
I mean you are something else really ah
but that's neither here nor there I'll
see if I have it I I feel like it's
probably got thrown away but I can
picture it you nobody's throwing that
away she might have cleared it out but
if that shoe box is still in there
there's a really good chance that that
album's there sure remember that album
that's CD
you got the vinyl uh but that's neither
here nor their gang we got a gosh dorm
Family episode where we gotta answer
your garbage questions when you join a
patreon you'll answer your garbage
question on the air baby shout out to
the [__] homies oh yeah we love you
we love the bozos the whole Army of
garbage comes in full force baby all
right this one's from Jeff ten dollar
homie ever pay for a haircut with a
check
that's probably back in the day I'm sure
do they even what was did everybody just
take a check
back in the day I remember like my mom
would use them for like a tutor or the
cleaning woman or you know at the Acme
or whatever I told I've written
maybe four checks in my life yeah all
I've bounced one I've bounced most of
the checks one was for drugs
I remember specifically because I was
fuming that the kid hit me up and was
like hey whatever
um
and then yeah I think two were the cash
that's bad they didn't necessarily go
through uh-huh as a Young Man
yeah they didn't I my checkbook
experience was very brief yeah I don't
even have it I don't I haven't had a
checkbook since I signed up for my
account at TD Bank like [__]
15 20 years ago but I was watching
Seinfeld the other day where he goes
into the Andover shop to get the jacket
where Elaine meets uh Craig sure
um the guy with the ponytail
he wrote a check for that jacket yeah at
department stores I don't ever remember
Patty I remember writing checks at the
grocery store because I was mortified
well that's what I'm saying but but even
though I had no idea what
it really meant I just knew that this
was a tough look I was buying you a
couple of days ago
that's all it was doing baby it was it
was fun for me to be gone yeah it was
kicking kicking the can of embarrassment
down the road yeah let's do this through
the bank not face to face I just knew it
was weird because it like really held up
the line yeah but back then everybody
dude even when I was a cashier at Acme I
mean
a good amount of people wrote checks
what was these and the best way to do it
the best way to write the check back in
the day the the guys who were because at
that point everybody's paying credit
card at that point like this was 2005.
or 2003 or whatever so it's like a lot
of people are still paying you know
there's a good amount of people still
paying in check you know one you know 10
15 of people are paying in check the
reason all that stuff went away is
because people were getting ripped off
right
or just into technology between you know
it became so much easier I mean how long
would it take the grocery store to
figure out that this check is bad
I think a day or two but then but then I
mean like writing bad checks like not
the person no like there's just no money
in there
yeah if there's no money if it's written
from the person like if I write you a
check and it bounces yeah I'm liable for
that money
really yeah like Kevin you as the Czech
writer is liable for the money oh yeah
yeah yeah you know sure I think the bank
might or the the store probably gets
made whole through the bank and then
they go okay we're gonna turn our sights
on
so this guy can't write checks anymore
did you have anybody like that when you
were banging no I don't think no I don't
think anybody was doing that but it was
also like you had to check for like
eight things on a check to make sure
like we had the if these eight things
weren't on the check we couldn't take
the check
signature the check number the Bank name
the routing number the check the
checking account number yeah I'm not
talking about fake checks
I think that's what people were
concerned about because then you're beat
sure then you're like you [__] up
there's no but you can't get the bank I
think will make the store whole
I think it's a real check if it's a real
check and there's just no money I
believe
um never a haircut
could have [__] because then you
don't really have any then you just have
the embarrassment you'd have to post a
picture of them going this guy writes
[__] this guy floats checks sure uh but
the the way to write a check back in the
day was at a grocery store or whatever
not to jam that lineup was come come in
with it filled out and you just had to
write the amount
you know what I mean it was then people
would go I'd go all right it's 103.98
they go 103.98 boom here's my day take
it and go out the door out the [__]
disorder yikes you never [__] with
checks right you're too young for that
uh just for like rent payments and stuff
I've never like written a check at a
store
that's like 80 [__] to me yeah yeah yeah
what about your mom you ever see your
mom write a check no like a grocery
store or anything like that no never
always debit card swiping yeah there you
go oh yeah classy broad oh yeah
um
let's see here uh all right this is uh
from Cody with graduation season here
what's a respectable amount to give your
little sister-in-law for a high school
graduation party what a [__] great
damn question fantastic graduation
because I got one coming up baby yeah
yeah great great question I haven't been
to
[__] I don't know if I've ever been to a
graduation party as an adult I was never
it was either not that was always the
thing I can you know up and you know
[__] running around doing spots and
stuff like that trying to try to make a
name for yourself
that what that always got sidelined oh
yeah even weddings weddings and weddings
were usually on the on the thing if you
know what I mean if it was the wrong
weekend and you know what I mean you had
a spot or something like that
a couple of funerals too yeah put me mud
in the face yeah you got it yeah for a
graduation yeah what that's like a
Wednesday beat it yeah working I just
had to miss one too because we were on
the road but a graduation a graduation
Yeah my cousin's kid yeah we're just
doing it's also like It's just tough to
New York to where they are I think
they're like they're like out by you or
like Delco it's like that's a hump to
get there and then I got the car I can't
even get banged up when I picture a
graduation party I picture a roasting
hot backyard with no pool I don't know
why sure that's what and and wearing
like being like kind of dressed up with
like an uncomfortable some sort of
collar on and you're sweating God dying
mismatched ankle socks yeah drinking a
half warm Corona talking to somebody
about something like yeah oh where are
you going next year oh yeah how's comedy
going when you grabbing that's good when
you I borrowed ten bucks you gotta check
on it uh where are my dad's clothes yeah
yeah
and I'm pretty sure I'm gonna have to
walk back to New York I'm 38 I'm wearing
my dad's clothes from 10 years ago oh
got one coming up good kid too real good
kid I would go is it like I mean because
I think the idea is to get them ready
for going away to college right like you
got to have some money when you go away
to college depends what your cash
situation is it depends what their
family's cash situation is I don't think
that should matter what their what their
family's cash situation is you're giving
it to the kid sure well I mean if they
do very very well you know I mean you
know the kids taken care of he don't
need your 200 bucks or whatever it is
yeah I don't think you should look I
mean I I see what you're saying but that
to me is selfish to look at what the
parents have to be like oh this kid
doesn't he don't need it you give we
give we give across the board it should
be the relationship to you
like if they're close like your nephew
should get 500. this guy goes to [__]
band camp all sudden gets some [__]
morals over here
I have a strict moral code what so okay
hold on this specific question is his
sister-in-law his sister-in-law yeah he
could be 26. it could be 26 and a Sixers
graduate in college yes his wife's
sister graduated from high school or
college or whatever
I don't know do you have a do you have
like a a USB I have no idea like we said
we never went because that was that was
always first on the channel I would say
now hold on a second I know what I'm
dropping on my boy because he's like
he's a good kid and I feel a little bit
guilty about your boy but my my little
cousin who's the graduation party I said
I have to go to oh okay
his other cousins like his sister and
and his his other older cousin when they
graduated I was I was I was on my it was
on my ass so they got nothing unless
they graduated six months ago you've
been on your ass the one the one might
have got promised something too I'll
send you something that never happened
sure but I'm gonna make it all up in it
with him that's just the lucky to draw
that's kind of shitty but yeah
to bring them one too should I do that
should I hey this was for you hey can I
make myself feel better or make this all
about me
okay how do I make this kid's graduation
about me huh bringing other kids over
here out there with [__] stacks on
100 you're [__] throwing them man you
are a [__] ham Arena this guy likes
the spotlight once the eye why don't you
play your short film for everybody while
you're there too see if you can get
funding you fat [__] idiot
you guys have a screen here by any
chance
here it's scooges
show
I remember doing shows there and just
when you start out in comedy you did one
with me there they're almost into our
relationship I know that picture just
but that was not too long that picture
just popped up in my dude your eyeballs
are like [__] in points dude looking
right through me
the devil's bag that night kids I think
it was nice
I think he got under the Dwayne Reed bag
if we're being honest
but I think I think you stopped it to
stop by clock so Smith fine before the
Great
I'm sure you got a real problem I picked
up a couple of things I gotta stop by
the Pfizer Warehouse real quick get my
head on the street
I [__] hated you that day oh my God
you had a shitty vest on you brought
that kid I [__] hated you guys were
so full you guys immediately passed out
of my car drunk while at like [__] 3
15 p.m on a Friday
[__] came in started cranking heaters
and passed out in the I was so [__]
mad at you dude
um
an all-time low for a lot of us
but especially the crowd that night oh
man they were about 70 years old
I'm so bad dude and so I was on pills I
had an excuse I was so [__] up that's
on roller skate uh
no but I remember when you start off in
comedy you you you don't go right to the
cool comedy clubs that like you're happy
to post about and I remember having a
post someone's I'm like hey you would if
the name of the place stunk you did a
better
you would do like the town I'll be in
Bryn Mawr on the 18th or something and I
remember some kids like where's it at
and I was like scoogies I was like oh
man that's
that is that's like out of a that's out
of a comment like a stand-up comedy
movie
but scooch is a great place to add a
little bar up front fantastic dude been
going there since I was a kid fantastic
spot yeah good Italian food over there
just the show the setup to the show
wasn't ideal yeah we stunk oh yeah place
was fantastic yeah oh [__] anyway what
were we talking about oh what to get
hold on hold on so you don't think I
should do that make wrongs right how
long ago was it uh I think they're both
juniors in college yeah that's yeah
you'd that'd look like an [__] that
would come off super weird to me
hey things things weren't good when you
guys graduated and I'm taking care of
your whatever I wanted to make sure you
guys were whatever
they don't need it either I'd be like
this guy killed a guy who's trying to
make a mess yeah that's what that that's
like My Name is Earl type [__] that's
like you [__]
that's that's too weird to dude if one
of my cousins if my uncle
dude if my uncle came up to him as a
junior in college like hey things
weren't sure great back in the day
here's 200 bucks I'm like oh hey buddy
take a [__] chill pill yeah right you
wouldn't take the two handy yeah I'd
look at you weird though I see what
you're saying okay I just think it it
it's the same I am very misguided with
all that it's the same thing as like
what you said where you tip the
construction worker it's like that same
like it just doesn't
it's a transactional is it's not a good
transactional point of that okay that's
all I think I mean the sentiment is good
I understand that my one cousin had a
birthday not that long ago and I made
sure I was a little bit you know heavier
with the yeah get it up to him on the
next graduation all right yes sorry I
was a [__] I I sorry I stiffed you
back in the day
here yeah that make enough they're
they're juniors they got one year left
okay [__] you know all right that's
when you hit them that's the that's the
time to make the transactions right
there I have a family friend that I iced
on their wedding too it's always
bothered me what are you dropping I'm
Hammer drunk yeah that's been I mean
let's move on from that what uh you
gotta I got a couple of notes flopping
out
come get it [__]
the crab cakes suck
I wish jammed up
I'm making I'm making my rooms right it
took Pat to the goddamn ended up
I'm [__] I'm doing what a guy can do
I can't just show up on people's
doorsteps with a bag of cash
bring a goddamn
pedophiles letting everybody know I'm
Kevin Ryan I used to be a piece of [__]
I just moved to the neighborhood
I'm still a piece of [__] but I got a
couple of shekels on me
if you don't remember I showed up at
your wedding with a plus one and didn't
have a plus one and I ate three entrees
and threw up on the dance floor and I
didn't give you anything uh yeah that
sounds about right uh man okay let's
talk about expressvpn baby expressvpn
let's talk about keeping your business a
private your business is your business
because you know what they say every
time you use internet with use the
internet without expressvpn and you're
putting your business out there yeah
it's like when you tried to pass a note
in high school did a girl that you like
and then then the class bully grabbed it
he reads it out loud he knows that
you're writing her poems and you look
like an idiot yep but with Expressions
that'll never happen with expressvpn you
can keep your browsing private yes uh
it's easy just fire up the app and click
one button to get started expressvpn
works on phones laptops or even routers
so everyone on your Wi-Fi is fully
covered it's just like a blight just
it's like a it's like a game of three
card Monty you're like where are you
what are you doing keep the feds off
your back yeah it's just like you don't
want everybody snooping your business
even sure like ads and stuff like it's
not even like you know like private
stuff it's just your information just is
he taking boner pills you're not taking
it
business protect your online privacy by
visiting expressvpn.com today that's
expressvpnexp r e s s vpn.com garbage to
get an extra three months free
expressvpn.com
expressvpn.com garbage today do it gang
it'll be our little secret now back to
the show well back in the day to get for
me my average bank account not
liabilities not bills that had to be
paid or debts I already had incurred my
average floating bank account was
probably a hundred and eighty three
dollars damn look at you yeah but that's
like
I owe Bill like I was like spinning the
plates I never had more than if I hadn't
if I had more than 200 in my finger and
I felt Rich you know what I mean yeah so
it's like now I got a wedding in Philly
I gotta get there
that's 40 bucks to get to Philly
so now I'm down to 100. that ain't no
Amtrak train no that's the three hour
to Warren
you're on top of it like The Darjeeling
Limited
electric you to my power lines oh tough
luck I'll tell you how to get down there
and then it's like all right I need
lunch or something the day before I
gotta get ahead stuff your fat face
don't you I gotta have fueled it so I
can drink more all day a pack of heaters
next thing you know I got plus I gotta
get home for another 40. real tight with
the ones at the bar too I bet you always
win I spent I tip them I hit him with a
[__] probably then I'd hit him with a
10 early hit him with it
hey hey jerk off over here remember this
big forehead will you I'll be back in
about 15 minutes you ever see a three
dollar bill huh
straighten me out for the next four
hours that's actually a collector's item
take it back
oh [__] but okay so what are you gonna
give to your nephew
um let's do the recommendations first
and then we'll see where you land no
let's find out what he does and then see
where he lands on the scale yeah okay
um
he might hear this
write it down
okay can you can you straighten me out
with a piece of paper and a pen
look
head Hans for me
we got the dog in the studio scratch the
dog's belly tell him I love them
uh okay T-Bone got us a pen and paper
write it down let's see where you fall
in the national scale does it give you
like high school call it like middle
school high school college okay yes I'm
assuming you sniffed them all middle
school too what the [__] hey what yeah
you're not getting you're not getting
paid I didn't get paid out for middle
school maybe a couple aunts and uncles
might straighten me out shout out to my
Uncle Mike and my aunt Colleen
um this is what I was thinking I think I
probably know I probably have like a
guesstimate
but you also are very bad with money
well it's about to get worse
there you go
all right
that was lower than I thought you were
gonna go give me it again
give it again that was one lower I
thought you were gonna get just one yeah
okay all right all right what do you
have all right don't Middle School
forget about it what would you give a
kid for middle school now that I now
that I [__] out of here nothing Middle
School no my my nephew I've given the
sex talk and tell them not to be a
weirdo
are you kidding me uh Middle School yeah
man if you're if your nieces and nephew
just said your uncles gave you stuff I
don't understand what you mean you just
said your uncles might have broken you
off all right four grand uh yeah
probably a hundred bucks or something or
maybe a pair of shoes or something
that's what I've been giving the kids
I've been I've been keeping the kids
[__] tight into Jordans that's pretty
good uh the recommendation is ten to
thirty dollars whoa seems wildly low to
me that's low these kids are rich now
that's what Patty does Patty Patty
usually goes low with the number but
it's very frequent that's good don't get
they'll get 10 on St Patrick's Day look
at 10 on Valentine's Day
yeah that's good okay
all right High School
30 to 200. what the [__] really 30 bucks
what is this from the 1800s this is from
2023. oh gee [__] 30 bucks
gotta be gone before the night's over
it'll be boozing I think probably the
now that I'm looking back I think most
of this it's not a wedding
I'm getting married I always I always
thought it was looked at as you you know
you give them the money and then that's
their nest egg to go away to college
yeah you know what I mean like they're
for freshman year may I think most
checks I got were probably 25 or 50.
maybe that doesn't make sense maybe I
think it was like 2025 was like standard
now that I think of it
graduation night
I didn't have a graduation party
everybody came to graduation night
and I think I probably got maybe
I don't know nine to ten envelopes
maybe pulled in 250 maybe three bills
yeah that makes about sense you got one
clue if you're closer to an uncle who's
got a little bit of cash we were leaving
the next day for Senior Week down in
Ocean City oh do my graduation money
didn't make it past Wednesday what do
you mean yeah I was [__] down yeah
um that and a sheet of acid stuffed in
the uh Restaurant at the End of the
Universe the book
it's always about food with you huh even
in space
[Laughter]
Foley you're the first man to reach the
end of the universe what are your
thoughts is there a Denny's around here
yes sampler talked this out uh okay uh
and then what was do they have college
they sure do I would I would assume
college should be smaller
than high school is the the biggest
accomplishment to me you're on your own
yeah College it's like [__]
you're 24. yeah
it should have been working
all right College 30 to 5 hundo 30th
what's with the 30. that makes sense who
did this Rachel Ray
remember when she was going around
Europe penny pinching no you don't
remember that show maybe it wasn't her
uh yeah Bourdain maybe it wasn't her but
I think someone somebody had a travel
show it was like forty dollars a day
give that a Google real quick
and they would go they would how you
could get a hostel uh no no it was just
it was just restaurants okay and they
would leave like a dollar fifteen for a
tip in Europe that's fine though maybe
it wasn't Europe
I'm telling ya I remember Bourdain
really really ripping on them for it so
yeah you can save money if you stiff
every bartender and waiter in the city
uh Rachel Ray's tasty travels okay yeah
it was 40 bucks a day right yep 40 bucks
a day yeah
well you live and you learn you know
what I mean sure
um okay that show was called that show
is called 40 a day the show she did
after it was race was racial race
station travels okay just use that pasty
travel
um all right so Foley was you know
do you want to reveal what you want to
give I mean that wouldn't be tasteful I
I agree I'll give you I'll give you that
it wouldn't be tasteful but 400.
it was
I thought you were gonna see you down
there big man I love you kids so he's 18
probably he gives a fight he's like fine
he's probably already spent it he hears
this he's [__] on Amazon right now
okay getting a blow up doll you know
what I get two three drinks for me I'm
going five how about that I thought you
were gonna go five because you think all
right let's go five you think in round
numbers like I do so I saw four I was
flabbergasted well I didn't want I
thought you you just would yell at me
why
for being too much no no why do you
think I'm always gonna yell at you they
think the other kids when they get
winded out will be like his [__]
[__] then then your [__]
bamboozle when they graduate college we
already went over that all right you
just can't go up to somebody and hand
them 500 but he would love that yeah
you're a dirt bag these are learning
people who made it to junior year of
college
I did not
uh all right fantastic question so there
you go [__] home run but it's that
season that's gotta go in the repertoire
sure but another I guess not a lot of
people know they don't go to that many
and it's like ah well yeah 25 bucks 50
bucks whatever sure
I remember I got a Trapper Keeper from
one Uncle yikes say buddy school's over
dude yeah
a drug dealer don't take [__] Trapper
Keepers
be some weed in here
so well this one's from that's not a
snack it's a lunch I assume it's in
regards to something you had said sure
never have on red is it garbage to have
to wait for a decent weather day to
trade in your car because the wipers
don't work and you don't want them to
find it out
classic Chestnut Checkers right there
yeah that it doesn't don't go in reverse
you don't need to if it doesn't work or
something that's a home run yeah that's
pretty good uh although when I dropped
the last car off
I mean dude I had crushed heaters in
there for three years straight yeah they
Deion I don't know you didn't give and
my whole time what's gonna happen when
you return it or are they gonna they
didn't he's like I don't give a [__] we
need cards I got no chips caught them at
the right time
a little chips T-Bone you gotta chip up
yeah ain't no chips uh they didn't know
I took the chip out put in my new car
and I got two chips and I got double
chip Jeep
uh all right let's see it goes sideways
this one's from Dion sandals long time
long time 10 homie here is it garbage to
take your bedroom door off the hinges
and use it as a beer pong table that's
nice that's a real college 20 early 20s
had like
hundreds of times I've played beer pong
where like a table had like a punch hole
in it or like you know like sure kicking
it from knocking it down or something it
comes off and then it's like well that's
the beer pong table can I say this
because I thought about taking the doors
off of my closet uh to have a little
more room in my bedroom and that's not
as hard as you would think taking doors
off hinges he just popped a screwdriver
in there those things come right out
yeah you know what I'm talking about the
doors got to be open though if the doors
closed that's why that's why they get
like kicked in and [__] what do you mean
what do you mean
not a front door like a bedroom door
yeah I think even those are the same
really they're all just on hinges yeah
I've taken a closet door off so that I
could make more space in my little dirty
ass room yeah just on the floor yeah I
want put your head in the in the in the
closet yeah wow that's sweet yeah it was
awesome yeah yeah put your little stuff
in there oh yeah that's cool I had a
little way too late dude this was this
had to have been like
2013. I had a did you have clothes
hanging above you in the sides yes
I mean we are [__] losers like a bad
Comedy Club it's T-Bone
and I had it it was like 2013 and I had
a combination one unit VHS television
that I would I would I bought a bunch of
VHS at a thrift store and I popped those
in but that was in the closet with you
yeah that was the foot of the bed on a
mirrored table Jesus Christ
luxurious I know
I would assume
that the answer to this question is no
I have one yes and it was a long long
time ago and they didn't have kids but
do you know anybody any adults in your
life when you were a child that had a
mere
on the ceiling yeah
cause my dad's boy did drove a Corvette
lived with this blonde-headed bimbo
sharp yeah that's where you want the
that's it was maybe that's just
Boomhauer it was maybe 82. that's the
neighboring [__] F is for family it
was some guy that he was in the Navy
with that we drove like maybe it felt
like three days with probably like 45
minutes away we went to see him on a
Sunday I met because I meant it was it
was the summer and they had the
fireplace going like what the [__] is
this place and it was real 80s and he
took he gave us the tour shag carpet
everywhere bringing a Coors Banquet I
bet dude one little man
you want to take a run at her
she's all here she's clean I tested with
it too went into his bedroom and he had
one of those like the posts on the bed
you know what I mean with like the
canopy yeah but it was a mirror and I
remember we thought it was so cool
I'm gonna give this a shot I remember
when Patty thought she was like oh get
out of there like drag this out of the
bed yeah I know what's going on in there
I think I remember I don't know who it
was but I remember there was one like on
but it was it was I don't think the the
intention of the bed manufacturer was
sexual mm-hmm because it was like in the
like on the headboard yeah the [__] it
was I know but it was very old it wasn't
like
that guy wouldn't have had it it was
like from like the 20s or something it
was very do you think I'm thinking
freaky back then you ever seen Boardwalk
Empire I know but it wasn't sexy it
wasn't like and it wasn't the whole
thing it wasn't like a [__] you know
was it just waist high
yeah no I think it would have even been
smaller I don't know it wasn't it wasn't
real wasn't it big enough where you
could do one of these
[Laughter]
pull the Bateman
uh I don't remember where it was though
I remember seeing that and being like Oh
that's [__] freaky naughty and then
being like nah I don't think that's not
it doesn't have the same vibes
probably at your band camp I wish we
were slaying plus back then
um all right let's see this is from Jack
ten dollar scumbag here never have one
red is it garbage if your dad
used to defrost the windshield of his
truck with a propane torch PS he ended
up cracking it
I guess when you're in a jam if it's
there's that much snow or ice or
whatever and you're [__] you're late
for work I don't know about you guys but
back in the day
de-icing technology
was tough
those are real tough the defrost didn't
work the way that it does now it was a
nightmare sure my dad would be out there
scraping oh yeah scraping you know what
people do now is they put a towel over
the
yeah the windshield and just yank it off
[__] genius I thought that would
never do that of course of course not
because I'm a [__] idiot now Kippy
would just rip the whole windshield off
yeah somehow sure
driving I wet it or something uh
yeah no I'll pour ice on it my pour
water on it myself I'm also very I don't
wait I [__] scrape just a little
circle and oh yeah it's got to be a
couple of feet before I start scraping
yeah
you got to be real dangerous when the
roads are bad the worst time to be the
worst time to lower your [__]
peripheral vision in my opinion that's
when the windshield wiper fluid and the
windshield wipers is supposed to show
the [__] up yeah but they don't always
especially if they got a little bit of
ice on them they're getting tested to
their limits I'll tell you that
um
trying to get that thing going jammed up
for sure uh all right let's see this was
one of this one's from Jay first time
long time is it garbage to run a
forklift while crushing Bud Lights my
company gets beers for everyone after
four o'clock and I'm the only one who
drives the forklift management doesn't
seem to care sweet gig that's OSHA's
playing I mean you get oh [__] to pop in
on that you are never popping I don't
know they never pop in on a Friday I
know someone who's got real that's
gotten whacked two three times real real
bad real but where the fines are like 50
Grand like they were like hey you've
been really [__] up
yeah that guy's operating a crane with a
beer helmet on
hey buddy you can't drive that Bobcat
with a catcher's mask on all right
uh this one's just a home run Grace is a
garbage if your karate studio shares a
wall with a gas station
that ain't [__] good that I mean
that's not a true Dojo if we're being
honest with you that's a Pep Boys yeah
presented by Amco uh
I don't even know in what world that
would even work because most gas
stations are Standalone Solo or connect
like they're by themselves with a Dunkin
Donuts or uh sheets or a Wawa like
they're rarely have you don't see them
in a strip mall I guess for safety
purposes they go up they go up yeah
you're not allowed I'll tell you what
that place that gas station is never
getting robbed it's awesome
building self-defense coming over the
roofs sure yeah uh I always do love when
like the drunk guy or the tough guy
probably crazy or something walking by
the boxing gym or the [__] those are
all set up no no there's this huge thing
if you ever like hear guys talk about it
but just some guy who thinks he's a
tough guy they're like drunk or on drugs
or just [__] off like you know cuckoo
bananas they usually get their eat oh
yeah they come in like you think you're
tough and then like that one guys like
all right I'll [__] you up I don't care
you know what I mean yeah it happens a
lot they say if it's just some like
weird
[__] lizard thing in their brain
where they're like you're not dumber
than me I gotta show you who's tough I
think you [__] bent up like a goddamn
Prezi
[__] Bavarian Prezi
uh all right let's see here we can do do
a few more
um this is from Dodge butt Ram Dodge
buttrum I don't even know what that
means ten dollar homie uh is it garbage
to put hot coffee in your cereal what
the [__]
who would do that
this guy apparently I could see it with
like an oatmeal maybe what what do you
mean an oatmeal listen while we're
living in a wacky world here I'm saying
I can see it where I can't see it at all
no but hence why I've never done it you
dump a little coffee in your vanilla ice
cream that's nice you do that with
espresso wait I'm saying is he saying in
replace of the milk or at it with the
milk
and I only drink black coffee so if this
guy drinks like extra cream extra sugar
that could serve as a [__] hot cereal
with Cocoa Puffs that would work that's
what I'm saying I don't know I just I
don't think cinnamon that could work
Corn Pops I could see that working gotta
stay away from like Fruity Pebbles or
anything Berry sure but cocoa powder
that's where they really come alive
Cocoa Pebbles Cocoa Puffs
those Reese's Puffs which ain't bad they
were too sweet and they cut the roof of
your mouth like crazy get stuck in your
teeth too all [__] impacted in the
back it's too sweet for me
Puffs were great all right let's see
this one's from Clapper the Snapper uh
did you ever sit in a lawn chair in
front of a high Collision intersection
drink and watch the close calls holy
[__] that's [__] that's like Joker
level [__] you want to watch the world
burn
that's wild
but a lot of times when people sit down
in their front yard they're looking for
a little action yeah of course yeah
that's like if you're looking out the
window of a hotel you want to see
something bad my uncle used to sit on
her front porch uh popping beers listen
it was a police scanner
yeah waiting to get tagged in yeah uh
waiting for action and then one day it
did happen it was a bank robbery or
something like that they cleared the
streets
was wild yeah
uh do you ever see I mean it's been
going around recently it was like the
ring cam of the guy the pizza delivery
guy in Delco oh everybody yeah probably
like a month or so ago with the kick
with the kick dude it's a high speed
chase like a guy's dodging the cops in a
residential neighborhood the pizza you
haven't seen the Stephen Pizza Guys
walking up with the like the food or
whatever
and the woman comes out as well and then
this guy like hops up on the front yard
of like across the street and he's like
yeah what are you doing and she's like
don't hit my cord so then like he loops
around and gets out of the car and he's
running like now a crop back across the
screen and he [__] trips them and he
falls with a back kick with a back kick
sneaks him guy flips falls on the ground
cops got him he goes don't run from the
cops [__]
that's all right yeah not too shy baby
that pizza place is fantastic oh yeah
probably I mean dude they're probably
that's now that what if they I'm sure if
Delco found out like the community found
out that that's the delivery guy from
that place yeah dude they're probably
they're probably flooded with orders
right now they probably do they're
probably constantly in the [__] weeds
to change the name of the place to
trippies welcome to trippy's Pizza in
mozzarella fries yeah you all go down
trippies bro oh damn that's good we
gotta wrap it up gang gang I'm gonna
tell you this right now we tell you all
the time we love you to death come see
us out there on the road get your
tickets to the Vogel theater August 11th
the second show that we added that's
gonna sell out tickets are cooking grab
them might be a couple in Cleveland and
Columbus
maybe well a handful were left so that's
probably sold out by this point we'll be
adding more dates check out all your
garbage.com we love you see you next
week